[Musica]
mi chiamo marco carrara da oltre cinque
anni conduco due programmi di
informazione su rai tre che sono il
moviolone di iago rampin talk politico e
timeline il talk di attualità
ecco da cinque anni dal conduttore
televisivo di programmi di informazione
o che fare con queste
le ciliegie voi direte cosa c'entrano
non è un film distopico ma è tutto vero
sto parlando del famosissimo fenomeno
molto molto attuale del cherry picking
come avete sentito poco fa ovvero
selezionare le ciliegie cosa significa
significa che quando una persona vuole
supportare la propria tesi la propria
fekih news la propria notizia falsa non
racconta tutte le notizie ma seleziona
soltanto quelle notizie che vuole
proprio per supportare la propria tesi
non viene non viene considerata tutta la
notizia tutti gli elementi ma soltanto
alcuni proprio come si fa con un cesto
di ciliegie si selezionano soltanto le
ciliegie che uno vuole le ciliegie uno
preferisce le ciliegie che uno a ma non
tutte solo alcune
se ci pensiamo è la tipica tecnica messa
in pratica è usata moltissimo dai
cosiddetti complottisti chi in questa
sala bellissima non ha mai incontrato un
complottista soprattutto in questi
ultimi anni no quando ti va bene è il
tuo zio al pranzo di natale
insomma chi ha incontrato il famoso
pranzo di natale quel parente che
supporta complotti teorie assurde c'è
tra quando ti va male il tuo collega in
ufficio e con cui a che fare tutti i
giorni il gomito a gomito di riascoltare
di ascoltare le sue teorie ecco da
conduttore televisivo di programmi di
informazione di attualità con i con temi
molto attuali come capitato di ascoltare
alcune volte questi complotti questi
complottisti supportare le proprie tesi
ecco
non è sempre facile
voglio portarvi alcuni esempio proprio
per capire questi cherry picking questo
selezionare le ciliegi queste questi
raccoglitori di ciliegi come operano
partiamo dal primo esempio il più
frequente il più comune anche il più
discusso eccolo qui
partiamo dal co lead lo vedete
l'argomento più amato da un tempo quando
non sapeva di cosa parlare si parlava
appunto del tempo che tempo faceva oggi
si parla di kobe si parla della pandemia
ecco prendiamo una notizia non notizia
vera assolutamente vere pubblicata di un
anziano che stavano in bicicletta è
caduto dalla bicicletta purtroppo perso
la vita è andato in ospedale è il
risultato positivo e ha scoperto che era
positivo ed è stato conteggiato come
morte perkovic ecco i complottisti
subito hanno preso questa notizia per
dire vedete questo signore non è morto
perkovic se ha scoperto dopo che era
positivo ma lo hanno conteggiato come
morte per kobe quindi i morti per kobe
da non esistono è tutto inventato
cosa è successo è stata selezionata
quella quella notizia di errore nel
conteggio perché questo è stato
veramente un errore nel conteggio è
stata selezionata quella notizia di
errore nel conteggio per supportare la
propria tesi i morti per kobe non
esistono sono tutte invenzioni peccato
che ci sono 6 milioni di morti per corvi
nel mondo non sono tutti 6 milioni morti
purtroppo e cadendo dalla bicicletta
secondo caso molto molto utilizzato
molto frequente lo vedete i cambiamenti
climatici e sul clima sapete no ne sono
state dette molte moltissime soprattutto
e anche nei programmi di informazione
ecco pensiamoci i complottisti amano il
freddo perché perché è l'unico modo il
loro modo per dire vedete fa freddo è il
riscaldamento globale non esiste è
assolutamente un invenzione per esempio
cosa è successo c'è stato poco fa a
marzo un marzo un po più freddo rispetto
al solito come tendenza stato un marzo
con temperature un po più rigide questo
l'ho fatto molti utilizzando anche soros
non ha detto vedete a marzo ha fatto
freddo molto più freddo rispetto agli
altri anni quindi di cosa vi lamentate
perché vi lamentate il riscaldamento
globale non esiste cosa hanno fatto
quindi queste persone chi proprio
pratica cherry picking seleziona
soltanto quei casi quelle informazioni
per supporto alle proprie tesi hanno
cercato quell'unico mese in cui per una
tendenza casuale ha fatto un po più
freddo per dire vedete abbiamo ragione
noi non c'è riscaldamento globale poi ci
sono altri casi sparsi chi vi posso
citare per esempio il caro benzina altro
tema molto attuale
e si prende il caro benzina magari i
prezzi della benzina del carburante
degli altri paesi per dire vedete noi
siamo quelli più salassati in italia
costa di più all'estero costa meno la
benzina
peccato che non si fa il paragone anche
con il carovita all'estero perché gli
stipendi italiani sono diverse gli
stipendi tedeschi francesi spagnoli del
nord europa eccetera eccetera oppure un
altro caso sempre in tema sanitario
rimaniamo in tema sanitario perché il
cherry picking questo selezionare le
ciliegie si pratica molto in ambito
sanitario per esempio si vanno a cercare
quelli anziani fumatori che hanno fumato
tantissimo e hanno vissuto lungo per
esempio fino a 90 anni per dire vedete
questo anziano ha fumato per tutta la
vita e ha vissuto fino a 90 anni quindi
fumare non fa male ho ragione io questa
è la mia teoria cosa hanno fatto hanno
cercato quegli anziani che hanno vissuto
fino a lungo per dire perchè scrivete
sui pacchetti che fumare fa male porta
alla morte non vedete loro hanno vissuto
fin a 90 anni ecco voi direte ma perché
marco ci sta raccontando tutto questo
non riguarda noi non siamo complottisti
perché ci sarà quotando questo fenomeno
come detto è un fenomeno molto molto
attuale ecco perché in realtà chiunque
di noi anche io per primo ci può cascare
chiunque di noi anche
involontariamente può praticare cherry
picking perché perché in questo in
questa dinamica entrano in gioco i
buyers cognitivi ecco l eccolo qua cosa
sono i buyers cognitivi sono quegli
automatismi e mentali per cui una
persona può prendere delle decisioni in
fretta e di fretta senza pensarci
proprio perché basate sono automatismo
sono quando pensiamo ci prendiamo delle
decisioni senza pensarci troppo per
veramente dettati dalla fretta dal poco
tempo basa su un meccanismo mentale
vi porto due casi per esempio c'è
un'opera realizzata un'opera bellissima
e l'ha fatta un signore anziano che da
tantissimo tempo è un architetto o un
giovane architetto alcune persone
basandosi su un meccanismo mentale e
automatico possono pensare beh l'ha
fatto sicuramente il professionista con
tanti anni di carriera alle spalle
mentre magari poi si scoprirà che
quest'opera l'ha fatta il giovane
ingegnere
oppure un caso di cronaca muore una
persona sono due gli indagati una
persona bianca è una persona nera alcune
persone basandosi su un pregiudizio
razziale ovviamente assolutamente
sbagliato possono pensare che va beh
l'omicidio e l'ha commesso la persona
nera perché loro si basano su
un'ideologia razzista ovviamente
assolutamente sbagliato quando poi
magari in realtà si scopre che la
persona bianca ecco cosa sono quei byas
cognitivi sono tutti quei meccanismi e
automatismi mentali che ci portano
compiere decisioni di fretta proprio
perché appunto
vengono fatti appunto in automatico c'è
un ultimo caso vi voglio affrontare che
ho lasciato da parte proprio perché
merita purtroppo anche vista l'attualità
di essere affrontato insomma a parte
parliamo della guerra in ucraina del
drammatico conflitto in corso anche qui
l'abbiamo visto tutti una guerra non
solo sul campo ma la guerra anche
informatica dove la campagna mediatica
informatica messa in campo dalla russia
insomma sappiamo che viaggia moltissimo
ecco prendiamo un esempio mariupol
mariupol alla città martire ma che
abbiamo imparato a conoscere tutti ecco
dov'è stato tra l'altro bombardato quel
teatro simbolo no noi oggi qui ci
troviamo in un teatro bellissimo insomma
è bene ricordare anche dove invece tutto
questo purtroppo non è possibile che
accada ecco a mariupol sappiamo che
stato bombardato anche un ospedale no
dobbiamo visto quelle immagini
drammatiche di purtroppo quelle donne
incinte che scappavano ecco cosa è
successo alcune persone sui social hanno
preso la foto del tetto un tetto
dell'ospedale con dei militari sopra
questo tetto per dire vedete ma i russi
non hanno bombardato l'ospedale con
civili con donne incinte all'interno era
un ospedale militare abbiamo bombardato
un obiettivo militare perché verde
vedete sul tetto ci sono i militari
peccato che quella foto era di un altro
tetto di un altro ospedale di un'altra
città di un ospedale simile accordi
mariupol cosa hanno fatto in questo che
in questo caso chi pratica cherry
picking chi seleziona quelle poche
notizie per sopportare avrebbe daisy
hanno cercato quell'unica foto di quell
unico tetto molto simile a volo di mario
poli per dire vedete è un ospedale
militare era 11 un asset militare non
abbiamo colpito insomma è un obiettivo
civile era assolutamente
11 un obiettivo e militare e in tutto
questo da conduttore televisivo quando
mi coinvolge è questo aspetto beh
sicuramente molto e voglio andare avanti
con questo perché oltre ai byas quei
meccanismi automatici che ho raccontato
prima c'è un altro effetto che entra in
campo che questo lo style media f
solitamente i complottisti hanno un
ostilità nei confronti dei media loro le
ritengono alleati coi poteri forti
pensate c'è una parola molto utilizzata
i giornaloni i poteri forti
loro hanno la convinzione che comunque
la narrazione proposta dagli organi di
informazione sia comunque alleata è
parte di un complotto di un sogno più
grande di un complotto bene quindi vi ho
spiegato cos'è cherry picking quali sono
i casi in cui più si verifica quali sono
gli automatismi che possono portare
alcune persone a creare queste fake e
news ecco
ma come si risolve tutto questo ecco
provare a risolvere questo questo
fenomeno sicuramente un obiettivo
importante no e forse c'è ancora bisogno
di lei la cara vecchia televisione dove
i nostri nonni sopra mettevano i
centrini no e ancora lei quella quella
attuale chi non aveva i nonni che
metteva il centrino sopra col
portaoggetti ecco tutti
ecco la televisione è ancora molto molto
centrale di dio penso che sono convinto
di un fatto che i social abbiano dato un
ruolo in più alla televisione che è
quello del fact checking come viene
chiamato cioè della verifica delle
notizie perchè perchè se sui social
viene praticato cherry picking si
fabbricano dell'effetto news e chiunque
giustamente può avere la propria
piattaforma per fare informazione ecco è
compito della tv prendere tutto questo
carico di informazioni selezionare fare
da filtro e portare in televisione solo
e soltanto le notizie quelle vere quelle
verificate chiaramente insomma è il
compito anche di tutti i media
tradizionali
un aspetto importante che io voglio
assolutamente sottolineare è che compito
di chi ha autorevolezza
sconfiggere lev e chiuso quindi può
essere la televisione che ancora negli
anni continui ad avere autorevolezza non
pensiamo alla famosa frase l'ha detto la
televisione
quante volte lo sentiamo questa frase
tantissima e la credibilità della tv è
ancora confermata per esempio dall
indice di ascolto soprattutto degli
ultimi 20 pensiamo alle elezioni per il
quirinale oppure in questa drammatica
guerra 9 gli amici di ascolto sono
aumentati però perché le persone forse
ancora scelgono la televisione per
informarsi soprattutto in occasioni
particolari nei grandi eventi nelle
grandi tragedie purtroppo in ogni caso è
compito delle fonti autorevoli e
l'aspetto piu importante voglio
sottolineare è questo il diritto di
scelta
scegliete
lasciatevi il diritto di scegliere
scegliete le vostre fonti le fonti
qualificate autorevoli dalle quali voi a
prendete le vostre informazioni può
essere la televisione se voi ritenete
che alcuni programmi siano assolutamente
autorevoli ma può essere per esempio un
giornalista che voi seguite moltissimo
sui sociale che pensate che sia
assolutamente autorevole o può essere la
stessa carta stampata l'importante è
rivendicare il diritto di scelta poche
informazioni poche fonti certificate e
scelte ma assolutamente scegliamo anche
perché in questo marans marasma di tech
news la televisione e tutti gli altri
organi che noi reputiamo torre voli
hanno un compito questo che non è il
canile la c1 nel canile in questo caso
ma deve essere il cane da guardia
dell'informazione come dicono in inglese
no il watch dog deve essere il cane
dell'informazione perché se sui social
chiunque può fare informazione praticare
il cherry picking quindi creare una
notizia falsa ecco il compito di chi ha
una testata autorevole essere questo il
cane da guardia dell'informazione quindi
per fare un recap vi ho raccontato che
il cherry picking è il fenomeno per il
quale si selezionano soltanto alcune
informazioni e non tutte per supportare
le proprie tesi
in questo ha un grande ruolo il buyer's
cognitivo cioè quegli automatismi che
per fretta ci possono portare a compiere
delle scelte
possiamo sconfiggere tutto questo
affidandoci a pochi organi
d'informazione ma qualificati
certificati assolutamente validi e forse
questo è l'unico modo per appagare il
pubblico continuare a infierire a
offrire informazione al pubblico e
appunto non lasciare il pubblico con
l'amaro in bocca
proprio come fanno le ciliegie grazie
grazie